yeah
mom Mommy's with the maggots down
have no fear this week's picks are the
opposite of Evil Dead they're good and
Alive along with the return of the
popular Evil Dead franchise we're also
serving up a guy Richie Thriller a
walking Phoenix drama a nun fighting
against artificial intelligence and the
final episode of The Adventures of baby
Yoda or whatever that show is called
Rotten Tomatoes is taking you to the
outer reaches of the Galaxy and Beyond
on this week's what to watch
[Music]
don't let it take my babies
heading into a theater near you is the
horror flick Evil Dead rise this marks
the fifth installment in the Evil Dead
film series which right there the fact
that they keep making them is reason
enough to watch it follows two estranged
sisters trying to save their family from
demonic creatures and was written and
directed by Lee Cronin but have no fear
Evil Dead fans because franchise Creator
Sam Raimi did serve as an executive
producer which could be why this one is
coming in certified fresh on the Tomato
Meter at 91 and if you are a big fan of
the franchise the critics consensus
should make you feel at ease about the
direction they've gone it says offering
just about everything longtime fans
could hope for while still managing to
carry the franchise forward Evil Dead
rise is all kinds of groovy yep groovy
more like nightmare fuel The Interpreter
saved my life and now I have to go save
his almond ended up with a price on his
head from the Taliban we can't intervene
I am gonna have to get him out myself
also opening in theaters is the action
thriller the Covenant more specifically
since there's a million the Covenant
movies this one is billed as guy
Richie's the Covenant considering he
directed and co-wrote it and since he
rarely disappoints that's reason number
one to see this movie plus it has a
pretty great premise it stars Jake
Gyllenhaal as a US Army Sergeant who
after having his life saved by an Afghan
interpreter goes back into a dangerous
war zone to return the favor and critics
aren't feeling this fresh film and
especially the evolution of Richie for
instance David Rooney from Hollywood
Reporter called it a great change of
pace for the director and variety's Owen
gliberman said we're seeing a born-again
filmmaker I had a guy you know cause his
name is guy right feeling sad about
going home
us feel totally unreal
I'm supposed to be leaving I don't know
if that's gonna happen another strong
option in theaters this week is the
black comedy horror film Beau is afraid
coming in fresh at 74 on the Tomato
Meter this one Stars Joaquin Phoenix who
has pretty much become a must-watch kind
of star with the unique roles he takes
and the success his films have seen and
for good measure he's backed by a strong
Supporting Cast that includes Nathan
Lane Amy Ryan and Parker Posey among
others but Phoenix isn't the only Talent
on a roll Who's involved with this
project writer director Ari Astor's
previous films hereditary and midsomar
are both certified fresh and we can't
wait to see what he comes up with next
and to complete the trifecta of
Hollywood momentum but I was afraid
comes courtesy of the Indie Studio a24
which has been behind countless hits
over the past few years including recent
Best Picture Winner everything
everywhere all at once that was so good
I'm no math whiz but add all those
things together and we've got potential
for something special it is a machine
talk
to you
if I say no it's just gonna send someone
else isn't it probably but it's not all
theatrical releases this week you could
also snuggle up on the couch for the
premiere of the peacock series Mrs Davis
there's plenty of good reasons to give
this one your time starting with the
fact that it has been co-created by
Damon Lindelof who's been behind a ton
of his shows like lost the leftovers
which is my favorite and Watchmen plus
the series which is certified fresh in
its first season Stars Betty Gilpin is a
nun who uses her faith to take on a
powerful artificial intelligence
technology
um hello talk about a timely topic and
speaking of Gilpin the Emmy nominee
brings a strong resume to this leading
role after great parts and shows like
glow and Nurse Jackie and joining
Guilford in the cast for Mrs Davis is
the one and only Margo Martindale whose
versatility in acting chops always
Elevate every project she's in like
scars in the galaxy
what do we stand for
finally and sadly another season of the
Mandalorian is coming to a close with
the season finale episode this week
following two certified fresh Seasons
this third installment is also certified
fresh on the Tomato Meter with critics
once again singing the show's Praises
another reason this finale is a must-see
is that the rotin Carousel of bomb
directors stopped on Rick from oyiwa for
the final episode who has been behind
some of the most action-packed episodes
of the series this far and as if you
really need another reason to watch it
is worth noting there's a fourth season
in development
that's it that's the list this week if
you don't love it already you will after
you watch one or all of these trust us
be sure to let us and your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and don't
forget to stop by the new rt25 page
where we're celebrating 25 years of
rotten tomatoes in all kinds of ways
including by offering you our brand new
card game putting your mind to the test
on 25 years of Tomato Meter scores
that's all for today fresh family until
next week stay fresh
[Music]